Now that we've talked about how to write exponents using MathQuill, I'd also
like to tell you what we do with fractions. You'll notice that if you want to
type 3 over 4 and get it to look exactly like this, all you need to do is type
3/4. Then, just like with exponents, if you want to continue typing something
after a fraction, to get out of being in the denominator of the fraction, you
just use a right arrow key. And then, you can continue typing like normal. So,
try out those first two with the instructions that I've given you. And then, for
the last one, which is a challenge problem, you get to use your new found
understanding of our wonderful MathQuill tool to write both exponents and
fractions. And even an exponent in a fraction.